i'm not alone
hello
oh wow wow wow wow
oh you guys are waiting there
hi
stan and kyle cool
so you guys got the
if you can hear me am i live right now i
think
it's so hard to tell on youtube
i think we are
hello
it's kind of cool
bam wow wow wow
your hair is getting long it is
it is man i'm growing it out i want to
go like way down so
that's my plan
what's up man
that was fast see you guys have like a
cool waiting room i guess you have that
on twitch too
but
uh with a thumbnail and a reminder and
everything
it's pretty cool
[Music]
uh
i need to do discord don't i probably
should
is the thumbnail the uh
the dung eater one yeah
i made a lot of them
in preparation for these streams
oh i see
it actually says we were waiting too
yeah it'll say like x amount waiting
right
i've seen that
very cool and i saw um
because i didn't have it up here but
when i went to my dashboard on my main
computer here
it uh it's it showed what messages you
were sending which is cool
very cool
uh okay let's get to my channel
do a little bit of that
god do the discord man
who wants to play
valerian i guess
interesting
go live
funk live on youtube
there we go
bang
you change your room around um i think i
decorated this differently than before
um but everything is the same
from what i remember
but the wall is different i think
not gonna lie boys our youtube's going
crazy
lately which is great
i mean a lot of fun with it too which is
the main thing
but the uh
videos are doing fantastic
lately
i'm very happy about that
finally
okay let's get into the game
is this song really not copyrighted it's
on a non-copyright playlist so hippie
sabotage
i'll be okay
sounds so cool
down a bit around 7k it's actually um
yes so it's more
it's weird because my youtube
studio will tell me the live view count
which is way behind what it actually is
because i think it's around like 11k
at least that's what it says in my
studio the youtube studio dashboard
and then i'll go back to the video and
i'll say like six seven k i'm like
that's weird but
maybe it has to catch up or something
but it's doing well
very well
my goal is always to get more views than
i have subscribers if i can do that
that's good
in my opinion
all right
the game is not currently launching
problem
problem
there we go
it launched we're good
we're just going to be doing more lore
hunting today we're going to look around
at random [ __ ] that's my plan baby
i lost my wife
and kill things
okay
my question
for
you today
is
do you like the holly tree area or no
where melania
a is of people are saying that that area
is dog [ __ ]
so i'm curious because i liked it
but i think a lot of people didn't
a lot of people did not
like that at all
that entire area let's go um
let's head east from here
see what we find
but yeah my hair is getting long
which i'm happy about finally
east
you actually pick up some pretty solid
uh what the heck
oh
she leaves some flowers
and a seed that's kind of cool
that area wants to murder you really
hard
i mean
yeah
everywhere wants to murder you
you're tarnish man
there's actually some good uh
smithing stones out here like that's
three smithing stone ones so if you're
like
have like a non-legendary item that's
huge
and then
i need them to shut up actually
go over here
this way i think
do you know you could break these
statues
uh with these giants down here
it's kind of cool i'll show you
nice clubs
thank you mom
i appreciate that
did i get its attention no okay you me
you
so these statues right here that have
the glowy part in the middle
they can run over them
and then they give you
five smithing stone ones and a smithing
stone two which is actually big
for early game like this is super early
area
that's big
a death bird
is the death bird attacking what what's
happening
i do not like death birds
also this giant is not laying off
like at all
i had no idea a death bird spawn here
why are they so aggro
no way
i ain't dealing with that
um
mm-hmm
that was a nice sound
okay i think we're good
i haven't been to a holiday since new
game plus kind of scared to go back
yeah
olive tree is rough
my guy
alexander's not there
did i already help him
i don't remember helping
him maybe i did
yeah i find it hard to believe i didn't
pick this up first
see these guys right here i feel bad for
because they
were
like
that thing on their head was forced on
their head and they're constantly just
trying to get it off by slamming their
head into the ground it's kind of sad
just always trying to get it off
sad
we'll put him out of his misery
oh he's still trying to get it off
you don't even care
cool
he didn't even mind for a second
also if you hit the top of his head you
do way less damage
because it's a helmet
essentially
there we go
i think i'm going to use this play
through and actually go through
everything i can in each area that's
that's what i'm doing
right now man that's what this play
through is all about lore hunting
finding everything i can in the game
taking my time going going through
everything trying to learn everything i
can
because i i didn't really know this in
my first playthrough
but
um
i finished my first playthrough in 58
hours which is
now i know is it obnoxiously fast like
that's super quick
you know more about these guys
it's like what kind of instrument is
that
oh i use carrying retaliation on this
build
[Music]
look at his uh sleeve right there it has
some cute gems on it
and his hat
[Music]
yeah i'm here as a customer
uh i'll buy all these that i can
and the notes the notes can give you
really cool stuff i must apologize
i'm afraid i'm very little to offer
that's okay
you go back to doing your thing
yeah carrying retaliation is super
broken
and i love it
love it
i think we just got some death boys here
bonk
a secret quest i don't think there's a
secret quest but they have a secret note
every single one of them do
that uh tell you uh
a tip
we can look at that real quick
and then we gotta kill a
boat lady over here
some some of the tips are like really
stupid but a lot of them are really
helpful
as well
um
i'm assuming it would just be info right
yeah
so all these are notes from merchants
that i bought them from
frenzy flame village south of the grand
lift of dexas lies the frenzied flame
village inhabited by the sick stay well
away so like that's telling you south of
the grand lift of texas
go that direction you could find that
um
a well-aimed bow to the chimney on top
may prove effective but opportunities
for a plunging attack will be rare
indeed for
beware the fire monks chariots bearing
the faces of the giants so that's a huge
tip that let's go check that out
actually because i haven't gone down
here
in a while
this this might piss you off kyle if you
didn't find this
because
it's kind of funny i know you get the
ball bearings but i don't want to kill
them
yeah you don't have to now that they
have names like indicators on the map
um
like
oh i killed that one of course i did
uh it'll tell you where they are
do you hear that
what am i hearing right now
scary
don't know how to get it either
we're gonna open this though
yeah you can kill the chariots
but that's like a tip you get from uh
from the merchants so
it's kind of cool
i forget which boss is down here
it doesn't look like they're up there
is this that really hard boss
i also don't remember how to properly
like get down from here
i believe this is it right
yeah
oh the tree spirits down here
ew
oh god
i'm going straight down
bonk
there's also a hidden area if you drop
off the right side of the bridge area
what bridge
my god can i kill the chariot here
no
i'm not actually attempting here i just
yeah i just want to take a little peek
cut that quite close
so not all of these chariot areas have
a way to kill them
only some
oh the bridge i cross gotcha
nice
we're good
i'm using a summon on this i don't care
do i even have that ability the heck was
that
i mean i must if i mimic use it
this build is really fun
this strength intelligence build is so
much fun
such a cool mix
yeah at least to where you can kill it
okay gotcha
that's okay
i'm not too big on the dungeon chariot
areas but we will check them out
and give it a look-see
or a little bit more of a look-see
uh i guess we can go check out this cave
did i help out um what's his name again
bach
how about bach yet i don't know
could give it a look-see
another thing i was surprised about with
youtube was
i wasn't expecting that after my
yesterday stream was over
for it to get any more views at all and
it like
it's progressively getting views over
time
on like a two and a half hour
video or live stream
so that was really cool
that's
passive
viewage and income which is awesome
that makes me feel good
so it doesn't put so much weight on how
many people are here in the moment
apparently people watch it later
it's awesome
oh
excuse me
see that's the dragon communion area i'm
pretty sure
to be a merchant right under here
youtube has been a dub so far
what do you need i'm still waiting for
them to get back to me about my channel
being monetized but
um i mean it was monetize
so
i said it usually takes a few days so
i'm just being impatient i just want to
know
i just want to know man
why am i running
in journey five i think i'm on journey
four
i think
[Music]
did i meet bach
somewhere
nope ain't here
hmm
do i go back
in feinbach
um
no i don't really care too much for bach
not too big of a dealio bro
hey here's another boss that i ain't
gonna care about using a mimic on
if you gank oh
oh here we go i'll use this guy
and my mimic
wow
wow
you know i bet i can
we can just we can check that out kyle
nice
i'm getting unfairly ganked i love it
i really only done this much damage
i can't even attack these things this
might be
my least favorite fight in this game
quite quite could be
i'm gonna get both of you right here
boom
there we go
that fight sucks
so you still get the needle
let's go see if we can give it to bach
now that's a good idea
that would be cool
so doesn't this open up the pathway
oops
to the dragon communion area
yeah this this area that i don't like i
don't like gank fights
i don't
where they have two really fast enemies
at the same time
especially with all the me i don't think
the boss fight would be that bad if
there weren't a bunch of like little
minions like these guys running around
too
like that was so
weird
and annoying
but it's not like it's a very
significant area anyway it's like not a
big deal
yeah see this is how you get here
i don't even know you go underwater
there
i forgot
am i a bad person for just hitting goats
as i ride by them in this game
it might be it might be
i guess
this is the dragon communion area right
yes
i find it weird that all of the dragon
communions in this game look exactly the
same like just like this
you murk box whole family so he can drip
you out it's exactly what we're doing
i don't have any faith or arcane so i
can't even use these but
it's cool to have
so these are the statues yeah
all of the heads are cut off
every statue
the head is cut off
interesting
what else is here like this is not
a giant area to explore
wow
we got some pingus
whoa
got some shipwrecks out
there interesting i know there's
shipwrecks by radon
but i haven't seen those
it's people trying to get here i'm
assuming
on top of the big rock
here
yeah
yeah there is
forget is there yeah it's right here
far to the east you'll find the
cathedral of dragon
far to the east is it here
here we go
it's not that far i guess
for the in-game world of this
[Music]
these little skulls are very interesting
wonder why they're there
yeah the rot dragon the scarlet rot fart
dragon
penguins aren't supposed to fly
die
man
hmm
little crabby boys
okay it doesn't seem like there's a lot
here
besides there just being a tunnel
those must be the shipwrecks
but why draw them in like a purple
like a person with purple clothes that's
very interesting
let's go back the way we were going
very interesting
let's kill a boat girl
what happens if i just laser beam this
this boat
i deserve that because i knew that was
gonna happen and i still did it
i still did it man
and now i lost my
wondrous flask
where did that go the hell
can this thing freeze
i don't think so because it's not alive
oh god
i've been having fun with the uh
intelligence build
i bet faith is just as fun
with the incantations
everything
nope you're supposed to die there we go
death root
i've never read the um death root
item description
it's not one of those
so i i could mix my wondrous physic a
lot like better i think as well look how
many of these loretta
jumping attacks i have loretta's slashes
i have four
um
yeah is that a key
it's gotta be
[Music]
death root
source that gives rise to those who live
in death the beast clergyman founded b
seal
sanctum in the distant east collects and
devours these roots
on the night of the dire plot that stole
the rune of death enabled the first
death of a demigod
later the ruin of death spread across
the lands between
through the underground roots of the
great trees sprouting in the form of a
death root
so would that mean that godwin
[Music]
is like the person who created these
because he's kind of infecting the the
roots of the archery
when ronnie killed him with the or the
black knife assassins killed him
interesting and killed his body or
killed his soul
now his body's just rotting around
i feel like i'm missing a lot
i didn't know there was one of these
here
ah
okay hopefully i have some
i don't
turtle can you let me in
mr turtle
let me in
i cannot ride turtle
i'll go back to torrent i guess
does that mark that for me
we'll just have to remember
die dear
um
i think we already have our physic but
we could go down there
we've been down there though let's go up
this way
oh there's a jump pad and take me right
back up here nevermind i'm going down
why are there two oh
yeah we can come back up here
did not realize these were here
yeah that's up to you kyle
if you don't like it you can always
respect back
you know
these are
these are everywhere
ash of war
sacred blade
neat okay
i doubt yeah the wonders physic would be
right there but i already have it
which this must be america
marica
yeah
same like flowing hair
as the at the end game
who's also this is also radagon
very cool
oh you don't remember where the face up
is around the map
well in new game you already have it
so it doesn't matter
you already have it
if you picked it up
if that's what you're talking about
i feel bad for hitting animals as i pass
by them but this is a video game
i just see and smack
wee
is so pretty
oh if you already got it i mean that's
something you can always check man
why is this giant out here
i really wish one of these giants were
like cool i guess eg's cool
oh my god he went right for the
this man went right at it man holy [ __ ]
okay it's frozen
oh you have decided
we are
the dragon
nice
nice
another church right here that's so
close to the other one
oh now we're getting in the caled
territory
was this read
lord godfrey at the last of his campaign
his golden armies
at last at the end of his campaign is
golden army's unvanquish and unbowed yet
finds grace lost
tattered and faded
my man lost grace
up i think we get invaded here
by the by the lady
i am going
to blaster
yep we're getting into florida
and
nice dodge anastasia
owned
we do not know much about here do we
what if i read that charm
would it just be
no
am i tripping right now
a little bit
maidenless behavior
listen
she came after me see here they are
alison's
which one should did she give us
was it this one
talisman carried by assassins who strike
unseen
no
no
i said it out loud to help me remember
and
now i don't remember
i don't know
maidenless behavior indeed though
langton
everyone has everyone's all made and
listen this game
well actually
i have
melana
guys who would you rather have your
maiden
be melano or ronnie
or anyone else
i would pick melano
technically ronnie is a doll
unless you're into that sort of thing
that might be kind of weird
bang
per serving
bosses
damn sometimes i feel like they're too
generous with the
checkpoints in this game
they're very generous
it's rotting everything rotting scarlets
the very earth that caleb rests upon in
celia town of sorcery
the end is nigh for us all
and yeah it looks like it mate
yup i ain't fun
uh lucian thank you
i'm not a dragon but you will be a
dragon kyle
soon
she gets a body by the end of it doesn't
she nope
she is a doll through and through she's
not real so she has to have a doll like
not saying she isn't real but she's a
spirit
she has no body
she can only that's why she has the doll
of her
that represents her teacher
rena
gross
but yeah is always a doll
man these things are uh useless
okey-dokey artichoke
oh yeah we got all these goofballs out
here
all right
we're gonna rain down
i did it too far back
now
mm-hmm
her body her body is at the top of the
uh
carrion's
study hall tower
or it's called something else it's not
called that
i'm dead
son of a [ __ ]
that didn't go well
yeah her body is uh
at the top of one of the like towers
where you get the great rune
which we actually need to go there which
i think i can
it's right here
divine tower of lurania that's where it
is
wish we could do that
the godskin guy
you can run past him
because you can use torrent
but uh
yeah not fun not a fun fight
okay i'm doing this again but with the
comments
see if i can kamehameha all the way
through
i can't alter the direction of it
how are you
ow
yeah you can just run past him there's a
lot of things in this game you can just
run past
but that's
takes away a lot of the fun you know
you see a challenge you want to beat the
challenge right
oops
i don't really need that
sounds good trey are we walking or
jogging
i guess we can go to the study hall do i
have uh what have i not done
for ronnie i'm pretty sure ronnie's at
asleep
which means we gotta go beat radon
yeah we got we gotta go down here baby
let's go
i don't wanna just sprint through caleb
but let's do it
please don't kill me torrent
oh god
[Music]
torrent will randomly kill you
too much treadmill shaking to type while
running oh yeah that's true
oh god
we are running away i do not [ __ ] with
birds
at all
nope
i don't like birds in real life so talk
about those things
no
it's a big no for me chief
hey it's finger lady
can i read my fingers no you know what
yeah i'll hit all the checkpoints that i
see on my way to radon we'll beat radon
and then we can explore uh caleb
later on
we don't have to do it right now
because i do want to take a closer look
at um
ronnie's real body like the burn body at
the top of that tower because there's a
ring i believe there's like a bracelet
or a ring
that looks a lot like the bracelet
um
that godwin has
i'm curious of that
these things suck
we should probably kill the dragon
we can kill the dragon
yeah incline is probably a really good
idea i wonder if i can incline that um
the thing that we have here
there's probably a setting where i can
do that
oh
i didn't even see it till this now
i don't feel bad for the mimic
i think this thing freezes really easy
too yup
nope i knew that was gonna start hitting
me soon enough i don't even
it's so hard to tell where that line is
on that
like where it hits you and where it
doesn't
yep we got the fart dragon
i just jumped into its mouth
get it buddy
oh god
sir i want to hit you in the head
oh come here
i like that though
oh my god okay never mind
oh my god
why do they not
it's so hard to hit a dragon's head in
this game
we're dead
thank you torrent
owl
god dang it
i know they nerfed the hell out of that
attack but it still looks so cool
dragon dead
okay
reminds me of like dragon ball z
kamehameha
what does this merchant have
yeah this guy's quick with it all right
i need that stone sword
this is where you get this helmet
oh
one
it's my favorite helmet
dang we're pretty much already there i
wonder if the festival's going on
or if i'll have to go up there
i'm not sure
uh
we'll find out
yeah i've heard incline is great for
cardio
i just don't think i have a machine that
can do that
you guys hear that the um the file names
for these enemies these giant weird dogs
are called dino dogs
like dinosaur dogs
which makes sense they remind me of a
t-rex
yep
festival's going on
all right let's beat radon
we're done baby
personally my favorite fight in the game
i want to make a lore video on rudon but
i want to make sure i get everything
wrecked
people on youtube are very
stingy
about what they uh
about lore
in these souls games
very
which is probably why body video takes
three months to make a video just make
sure everything is right
this is like such a cool area
who is this woman
does anybody know who this is
she is randomly here
she doesn't talk
she just bows
and that's it
doesn't nothing
what we find out she's like radon's wife
or something
i was a little
our
worried
but
it looks like you're still in one piece
i'm using your sword must have heard by
now right but star skirt radon holds
ronnie's fate in stasis
but once he's out of the way
it'll spring back into motion
so now
we stand against the demigod once known
as the strongest of them all she's a
maiden
[Music]
i know that
random finger girl but why there has to
be a reason she's here
to fight radon like what if this is
radon's maiden or radon's wife
consort whatever you want to put it
and she's just trying to uh give radon a
proper death
trying to help with that because that's
the whole point of this festival is to
give radon the uh in honorable warriors
death
in battle even though he's lost his [ __ ]
you know
[Music]
were these ghosts always here chad
i don't remember them always being there
prepare for battle
defeat the general
claim glory
and grab that great rune
a celebration of war
[Music]
i feel like they could have given him
like some animation up there right he
has animations for the second half
after he talks
but
for that he just kind of stands there
like you could like raise your arms up
something i don't know so it's a tiny
gripe that does not matter but
i thought that my first playthrough
the festival begins
i love how it's ready as i'll ever be
it's not yes
it's ready as i'll ever
be because uh this is gonna be rough bro
before we begin
allow me to paint you the full picture
such a cool cutscene
[Music]
there's so much screen tearing
for me
which i think you guys can see too
ton of screen sharing tearing
in the cutscene
like right up the middle there
eaten from the inside by melania's
scarlet rot his wits are long gone
now he gathers the corpses of former
friends and foes are like gorging on
them like a dog
[Music]
is that the girl who was standing
outside are you looking at the sky
is that hearth and
phenalia the nail i don't know how to
say things
see now he has an animation
festival
boom
yeah i know i know you can summon her i
just didn't know who she was
so she works for
celebus
i see
so celebus
works for ronnie obviously
and he sent her here to help us kill
rodon
so that
um
ronnie's destiny like the stars can move
again that makes sense okay
neat
good to know thank you
all right let's get it
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah i haven't done a ton of
i'm going to try and do most of the
quest lines in this play through
i haven't messed around with celibus
very much
but uh i have his flask that he wanted
me to give to nafelli so we'll see what
goes on with that later on
yeah he's he's sketchy as hell he's
he's a dick
nice
let's get it baby
[Music]
i might try and do this without summons
now you can say as much as you want this
is my fourth playthrough
so don't worry about it
i don't mind
i'm looking for answers at this point
so now after the nerf you can dodge away
from these now like you used to not be
able to outrun these
now you can
are you gonna shoot your [ __ ] in the air
no
okay still have a shotgun
ow
that hurt
not doing very good right now
oh my god
that hit me
okay
it's a rare one
so now we're going up
that is the coolest [ __ ] thing man
i don't even know what hit me there to
be honest
this is bad
nice
what is radon's great rune dune again do
again is it uh health
i think it raises your health
i love the lore even more so in this
game than previous entries
i love the lore in this game too
bloodborne's lore is hard to beat though
bloodborne is
bloodborne is a [ __ ] masterpiece of a
video game it's so good
i love uh sekiro too
not as much on the lore there but
the game play is awesome
elden rings got it all though
max hp fp and stamina nice
where do i turn his in
we're gonna have to go to a bunch of
places
they do the optional side quests before
this the ones fallen omen slayer of the
the fallen omen slayer
no i don't think so
never played bud oh my gosh bloodborne
is a must-play game
if you can get your hands on a ps
borrow a playstation from a friend or
something
like it's so good
i don't think so scream
not sure though
ah good
i was waiting for you
i want a sick way to fighting
the glory of the king i love blood
blight
and you
and
did you see that afterwards
falling star right before our eyes
i can't fathom how radon who's holding
back something of that scale
he was a living legend if ever i saw
i'll take a look scream the path has now
been cleared
irani's fate will be decided
let's meet with a falling star with the
earth
we'll take up our souls once more
for mistress ronnie
poggers
can we look like
can i look through a crack
because he gets all cracked up in this
game or in this fight
oh like i'm looking right inside him now
doesn't look like there's anything
actually in there i don't know what that
is i think it's just a leg
but he fills his pot with the blood of
his enemies
are the guts
it was a battle marvelously fought
frame rates dog [ __ ]
yeah
the old ps4 days you know dude
we didn't know how good of a frame rate
we could have
stand
out
it's kind of bad astray
i love the way like his voice actor too
the way he talks
there's a veritable mountain of warriors
bodies right here
if i can just squeeze this bunch down
inside me so you squeeze down inside me
the body's found here are exceedingly
fine
who could expect any less from the very
warriors who fought in the shattering
the greatest of all wars
just you wait and see friend i'll grow
even stronger i have a question
when next we meet
um do we know how long radon was out
here wandering around
it's the shattering happened long ago
but i don't know when melano melania
excuse me i don't know when melania and
radon fought
it had to have been a long time ago
right
like hundreds of years maybe like one to
two hundred years
just to give a guesstimate
that he was just wandering around
because if you look i didn't i didn't
point this out during the fight but
radon does not have feet
you guys notice that his feet are gone
and i'm assuming it's from him wandering
around and dragging his feet to a point
of where they just
came off probably from the scarlet rod
as well
um
that's my guess
had to have been a long [ __ ] time but
if you look in the trailer
before
radon and melania fought like not in the
game but the the trailer before the game
came out
he uh
he had feet
and now he doesn't during the fight so i
was like
i don't know why that look like i
noticed that
i'd say about four eons ago during the
age of the rapid antagonist crucible
clerics
how long is an eon i don't even know
kappa doesn't work here
yep we got we'll figure it out stan
i know what you mean when you say kappa
that's good enough right
because uh youtube's been kind of a w
not gonna lie
compared to twitch
the onion knight yeah yeah uh what was
his name i know you're talking about
though
thousand years is that an eon so 4 000
years ago
man
i guess that's possible we don't really
know
what what are the emotes on on youtube
hold on
oh i have to sign in to shad i'm not
going to do that
i think it's a billion gazillion years
so just like everything it's vague and
we don't really know
siegward
sig
sigward
i keep thinking squidward
what is that a flag of
whoops
let's go check out this dungeon over
here
you know what nope we'll be back we're
going to do what we came for we're going
to go back to ronnie
uh
well we don't want to go back to ronnie
yet we want to go to
nocron which is
here now
so let's go here
a billion gazillion years
i don't know
i don't know how long it would take to
infect
uh
radon with the scarlet rot
right because
radon is the son of radagon
and ranala
and i
from what i've read in the lore radon
idolized radagon so he wanted to follow
the golden order which is the golden
lion on his armor
right so he was the general that is true
it makes sense
where are the rocks
yep
it's a long time that's that's as vague
as as from software is gonna be you know
and eon is a billion years
yeah i don't know if radon was out there
for a billion years
but uh he was out there for a long time
that's that's our answer
long time
oh excuse me that's what i meant godfrey
not ratagon you you are right he had to
fly he idolized godfrey
yes
you are correct
misspoke
where are these floating rocks
can i say i love it when a game will
like change the map around for like
stuff that happens in the game this
isn't a huge change but like putting a
giant crater
in the map
ow
with floating rocks above it is so cool
to me
okay here we go
that boy is not gonna come after me now
character looks sick i
am having a lot of fun with this build
it's a lot of fun
a long long time ago in a kingdom far
far away
it's the best way to tell a story
disney
star wars
something
all right no
not intelligence and strength build
mainly
like i got my big ass sword
but i also have
spells and [ __ ] it's fun
yeah george lucas
a long long time ago
in a galaxy far far away
yes i'm a smart ass
exactly
ow
i love this uh ash of war too
wolf's assault very cool
why are you scooting away
ah it didn't work
are they immune
nope that spell is just janky
okay you guys know we gotta cheese the
mimic up here you know
we gotta cheese it
take off all our clothes
all our weapons
throw it all back on
can't even hurt us
okay let's try the beam again
he walked right into it
see that that arrow came in way hotter
oh
you guys need to remind me i have no
idea why i popped that that was an
accident um
it doesn't matter
you guys need to remind me to go and
find
big turtle dudes with the bells so i can
get the remembrance
of rinala again so that i can get her
moon spell
i want to use the moon spell it is so
cool looking
because i i used her remembrance to get
this staff which is hers
so i gotta do it again
but at the big turtle bell dudes
whatever they're called
die
actually i'm running away
we have a goal we will be back here
[Music]
and explore another time
did you steal it no
i took it
is there a difference
mausoleums thank you
and no there is not
all right you know what i'm doing to
these chick
these chicks
check it out
all right you see you're lurking up here
seeing or lurking right here
[Music]
just gonna whip me
daddy what
stop it
oh double sword sounds fun is that just
like a pure strength build or what
what's the sword you're using
that does sound fun
the meteorite's not very good actually
but okay
chat close your eyes
oh wait i don't want to do that [ __ ]
what do i have on
all right we're gonna do no talismans
for this fight
close your eyes chat don't look
beep
do i have to get rid of my spells no my
mimic can't use the spells
sounds good beep
just throwing these on for now
[Music]
hello
[Music]
guys doing a lot of damage as you can
tell
just throw a rock at me
[ __ ]
[Music]
dang he's actually strong
it'll take so long stan i've tried to do
that
i took your flash away
i remember doing that
[Music]
frost is probably the strongest
like uh effect in the game
i don't even think i can parry
i can parry never mind
the timing on that
i didn't realize i could still parry
with the retaliation on
owned
[Music]
where do i have rocks
all right i'm over it
it's the funniest fight in the game
what a goof
who is me
yeah i've tried to beat that guy with
just my fists before
uh it takes forever
forever
uh dual bleed daggers is super fun until
you get the bosses with the weird
hitboxes
yeah
i can i can definitely see that
two rivers of bloods moonvale
dexnet
i d i did a run with i did a bleed build
with uh with two rivers of blood as well
and they were actually really fun
that was super fun
oh wait i need to make sure i have
everything
so what would be the best [ __ ] that we
could use here so
increases damage taken
right we have radagon sorceal and
america's sorceal
should we look at these
an i engraved
with an elden rune
said to be a seal of queen america
raises mind intelligence faith and
arcane but also increases damage taken
these seals represent the lifelong duty
to those chosen by the gods
that's dope
okay
vigor endurance strength and decks if i
had both these on
i'd just be better
buy a lot
oh [ __ ] i might throw these on
and just not care
no these would be good if i wasn't
already overpowered yeah okay
raises intelligence sure
vastly boosts physical damage negation
yes
okay
i thought america was a god technically
ratagon is america and america is
ratagon they're the same
thing
they are gods they're demigods
they were chosen by
the greater will
or the two fingers
born into it
slowly restores hp
raises vitality
you guys didn't know that
oh yeah
america and ratagan are the same person
hopefully that doesn't like spoil
anything but you didn't know that now
you do
fp lowers fp consumed by skills
i feel like i want that for like what i
do
is the max number of talisman slots four
i think it has to be
raises defense when max
hp successive attacks restore hp
restores hp upon defeating enemies why
not we should do that
i think we're good okay
let's get it
now i'm confused
i mean you guys let me know any
questions you got hopefully i can answer
it
wasn't her and radagon both gods even
before they merge no
ratagon does did not
exist
before
america
use the elden ring
to split herself
from the uh not split splits a weird
word
but that's technically what she did
because she was cursed by the fire
giants with red hair
so to get rid of that curse
she used the power of the elden ring
to
split herself which created ratagon
and then she used the power of ratagon
to
like take go to the lands between
or at least fight against the carrion
empire which had been ranala like and
then all that [ __ ] as well so
how they got so it's probably a
mistranslation
because there's apparently there's a lot
of that in the lore here
what is that oh that's a dude
it's uh
the greater will are not gods they are
the universe they're
everything right
gods are
[Music]
you know all of these
insanely powerful beings
but they're not the greater will does
that make sense
so like they're the greater will is god
quote unquote
the great like they are the everything
they are the universe
everything and these
demi gods
are
step below like i want to say a step
below but
does that make
sense probably not
it's all very confusing
it's fun to try and figure out
what does this guy say
because that's moguin palace
i didn't realize there was like red
blood coming out of the mountains there
as well it's kind of cool
is that guy still standing there
no
it doesn't yeah exactly you gotta
you gotta think outside of the box for
like what makes sense in our world
and what can make sense in this
completely
different fantasy world right like
it
you gotta
sometimes you say there's the greater
will and then there's gods
two different things
there's a lot of bloodborne in this game
maybe a lot's not a good word but
you can definitely feel bloodborne in
this game for sure it's awesome
the biggest comparison i would make to
this game to any other from software
game would be dark souls 3 though
[Music]
oh hey
holy [ __ ] i got stuck
yeah
yeah the lore is so hard to explain
that sometimes like you know i'll try
and make lore videos and stuff and some
people just be like no you're wrong that
[Music]
that's not what i think and it's like
okay there could be two different
determining factors here of what we
believe that's fine you know we can all
calm down
some people get very angry
it's like that's not what i thought it's
not what i think okay
you think what you think
i'll think what i think you take you
take it or leave it
i mean this is the
this is all of their games put together
for sure
hello
can't parry those by the way it's not a
spell
damn he's gonna kill me
it's gonna hit hard
frost is so good
there we go
maybe great one in bloodborne and outer
gods and elden rings somehow shared the
same universe
you want to hear my theory of elden ring
what i what i think it is
i think it's a i think the entire thing
is a dream
none of it's real
it's all
like
just a myth that we're also experiencing
and think of bloodborne
the hunter's dream
all that stuff man
it's like good
it's an interesting concept
if you use any kind of fire after
getting a frost proc you can reset the
proc bar
i like that actually
the lands between is a dreamland that's
what i think i mean when you think of
the lands between another
another theory i have like instead of it
being a dream is that it's purgatory
it's between
life
and death
it's between the greater will
and it's like between heaven and the
gods and hell below you know like it's
there's a lot of things you can think
about this man i a purgatory
dreamland type like it's not
it's not real
you know
very interesting concept
you get the mimic tier over there which
we do not need again
we also get to fight a ball
great
perfect
yep between light and dark
there's a lot of theories there
well i haven't really heard that theory
that's just what i
think what is that i don't like that
ma'am stop it
okay now you're dead
i think it's the painting world that the
girl in dark souls 3 was painting
that's a good one that's a good theory
i like that one
you say that anywhere on the internet
though could be like no it doesn't make
any change
that's not what i think
i like it though
very well could be
because that's what the dlc was all
about was this painting of the new world
and then we never got it
it's like what are you painting
and then you think about all the
paintings right
all of uh
are they all these
all paintings that we have found
literally showing us the world in front
of us
that we're a part of who was it painted
by
who are these artist shacks
you know what i mean
that's that's pretty [ __ ] good that
could get people riled up man
i like it
oh yeah that doesn't fully kill you bro
oops
between death and rebirth
that's yeah
could be
there's a lot of rebirthing in this game
of course that does 605.
this thing has 606 health
oh my god
we get a big boy
[Music]
i'm gonna nuke him though
[Music]
that was quite literally the coolest way
to kill a giant
that was [ __ ] awesome
freaking classic dude the the one
handing this weapon does 605 damage
enemy has 610 health or something
the land of ashes
so this could also be a prequel to dark
souls
you know like
i don't
know the the whole point though is that
it it that theory cannot be completely
dismissed
because we don't know for sure
well
actually if you killed him
in this way that i prefer
okay kyle
calm down buddy
let me grab my phone
[Music]
we
[Music]
excuse me kyle
actually
that's
[Music]
see look at that dude 10 000 views
hey man i'm from the internet
i'm right
bruh
i also love it when like people will
watch the entirety of one of my videos
and they say so the formatting of your
video is quite confusing uh you should
try and do it more like fatih vidya
he uh really compiles it down into a
very uh sophisticated
[Music]
like okay
go watch body video then video man
comments have been fun lately
um let's go to the tower
right
yes
we go
[Music]
wait it still gives me all those areas
that's weird i'm just gonna do this
are these the gauntlets that i want i
don't really know if i like these
because i remember just putting these on
without even thinking
elden lord racers
bare hands
nah
[ __ ]
i don't fit
um
scaled i believe is what i was using
light springs are fine yeah
mausoleum time soon
i want to do this ranny questline first
and then we'll find a mausoleum
wake up
it was
not blythe
even in my sister well blind help
me it is in my possession is it not
the hidden treasure of knockron
my thigh no crime
finally all the pieces are in place
soon must i begin my journey
upon the dark path only i may tread
ah
but before i leave
i shall entrust thee with this
blight as a [ __ ]
he really is
and it sucks man
well he can't be a cuck
such as
blight is ronnie's stepbrother
which i guess
that would be weird i must thank torrent
too for his part
you may leave now i think he loves her
but like a sister not like uh
like
that just like will smith
oh
man
dude that
i'm still like confused as to what the
[ __ ] happened at the oscars
like that was wicked
hey man it's royalty hey george rr
martin hey they wouldn't be step they
wouldn't be step anything it'd it'd be
brother sister
you know
shadows signed her by the two fingers
yes but eg tells you that
blight is ronnie's step brother i
believe as like think of it like an
abduc adopted dog like even your dog
you say would call like your daughter or
your son or your brother or your sister
depending on who you are in the family
because you get what i'm saying
he is her shadow
that is right just like malakath
is
queen uh america's shadow
familial love
familial love yes
indeed
stop it
i think they should have made these
wolves out here non-hostile
because like i don't know blight likes
us or something
light is a dog
exactly that's what i meant by that
exactly
so he is connected to her like that's
his like duty
is to be her shadow and to do what she
wants and
what's crazy is blight fails and
malakath fails
i remember the part about a brother
eg tells us that like he straight up
says
blight is ronnie's stepbrother
and they both grew up together
like his best friends
did i get a talisman
i didn't get a talisman i got the
inverted statue which we can go
therefore
oh you want me to show you that one it
was the
oh look i'm gonna get it wrong if i
guess
taker's cameo restores hp upon defeating
enemies
is that why he gets mad when you're
maiden
he gets mad because he failed
he didn't do it himself
that's why he gets mad
he gets jealous
and ronnie is really not nice about it
either
isn't ranala her sister ranala is
ronnie's mother
ratagan ranala had ronnie
radon and reichard
oh no he's jelly but to your theory of
the painting
why are these here
who's the painter man
who's what artist shack
you know
you know what i'm saying kind of weird
i i like that dark souls 3 theory that
is interesting
that's wicked
wait i gotta go this way
right
yeah
no
melana and ronnie is ronnie's sister
i don't know if you saw my video on this
ari
melna and ronnie are the same person
what that yoga what
and i'm pretty sure that's like
right on the money
it is a theory but i think it's very
sound and is like i'm like 95
sure
that they're the same person just like
america and ratagon are the same person
how they split
each other
when ronnie split herself
as well
they became like two different
beats
because melania is like
just a spirit
or yeah
it's so hard to explain
that was everyone's take on day one i
did not think that at all through my
first two playthroughs until until i
started looking at it
they're like split
because ronnie
is a doll she's just a spirit
it's just a theory
that's what i think could be wrong
i mean
it would be uh
i just watched my video on it there's so
many examples
what soul died
the great rune
melania could be ronnie's great roon
like the just as she discarded her body
she discarded the great rune because she
doesn't want to be
uh what the two fingers want her to be
that's melano
that takes you down to a really cool
boss fight
we're not going to do that
not right now
i want to get up there so that we can
look at her body
for research
research
there's also a lot of theories with like
the the glomide queen
um with melanoma which that also makes a
lot of sense too
i think if we want full constructive
answers to all these questions that we
have
we're gonna have to wait till dlc
and i wanna look at her bracelets yes
we're gonna have to wait for dlc
doesn't melt us want to kill us for one
of the endings when we're the flame of
frenzy yes
we're the lord of frenzy
lord of fame flame frenzy so many things
yes she wants to kill us
because that is just like [ __ ]
not
what they want it all
that's a whole other like
hey you want to just have everyone in
the whole world go into chaos baby
let's [ __ ] him up
like if you want to go that route you
can
aren't you dead though i don't know
like are you really dead because think
uh if you do the lord of frenzy ending
when you go to the uh
you know the flame of the giants you
fall into a pit of fire where it's like
aren't you dead but then you end up in
the city so it's like
you know what's what's really dead
and then you think like is all of this a
dream like there's so many instances
where like i'm pretty sure we're dead
bro
but we're
not you know what i mean
it's it's interesting
very interesting
all right chat i hate this wizard
with every fiber of my bean
this wizard can
can smell it
yeah what is death you know
we can devour the gods together
away from this edge man
he loaded that one up huh
i'm like panicking or what i want to do
i am so good
god damn it
shoot me
now peasant
i'm laser beaming you i don't care
that's about how i thought that would go
sir i'm trying to clip to you and i
can't
here we go
it's a fun little battle
what come at me bro
not my best play
there we go
that made it a lot easier
dude i hate these spider hands
malkith knows about death yeah he does
he's also a failed shadow
death be my blade once more
i think that we had that i think what we
have for the frenzied flame ending is
half complete at the end if you teleport
away
and melania vows to hunt you down i'm
thinking you're going to wake up in
another area like pharaoh missoula
maybe
that's potential
if you think about it right kurt isn't
even right kurt when you fight him it's
the serpent who devoured him
transforming both of them into something
else yeah it's literally just the snake
like he got [ __ ] up by a snake
and that's pretty much
like
gg
for him
but you can't i don't think the snake
could kill reichard because reichardt is
a demigod right something like that
so they became
that
oh platforming so good in this game okay
oh god this might be a little high
we're good
i wonder why there's a huge tornado
lifting up foreign in my favorite
location
that location is really cool
apparently that's like
i don't know why it's a tornado
but you go there to be rid of the flame
of frenzy don't you so like let's say
you chose the flame of frenzy path right
chat
and you want to be rid of it you're like
no i don't want to do that
you go to pharah missoula and you go to
the boss room with the dragon lord and
that's where you can be rid of it you
can get rid of it
there
i'm not sure why
i think it's because time stands still
there because when you enter that boss
fight time stops
and the tornado moves so you can go into
the boss room
but there's like
a lot of speculation there
a lot of speculation there
yeah yeah more questions
we don't need more questions we need
more answers
you do it
in the boss room but it's like before i
don't know i forget where but it's
before the walk-up to the to the dragon
lord kyle
yeah the the dlc could make more
questions like who knows man
was shattered by the natural born of the
void arriving
that's it i need to explore that area
more i really do
before mankind existed could be
very well could be
okay
i don't care i am using a mimic on this
stupid boss
i don't know why but i i hate
god's skin noble
i hate him
i do
come on
can i even use a mimic nope
never mind baby let's get it
actually you know what sir throw throw
your flames at me my guy
throw your flames at me my guy
come on
now let's see how well this goes for you
bro uh-huh i bet that hurt
uh-huh
wow so strong
so big
this is great
this will make the god skin duo a lot
easier
oh god
i knew that was gonna happen
nice miyazaki
throw your fire
perfect
you see that perfect straight backward
doing nothing
nice that that made me look kind of
badass i ain't gonna cap but now that i
mention it i don't look badass at all
perfect
jake you should make a video called
every item and their description in
elden ring
do you want to kill me like
you have do you have any idea how long
that would take just go to the wiki
hell no
oh
want me to read all that too i'd be
reading a [ __ ] book
there's a sword that mentioned how ferum
was damaged in its description
which one i want to know
i want that sword
yeah just use the wiki
someone said
gramazole was floating above lim grave
due to demi humans
why demi humans though
interesting
i gotta upgrade this the shield as much
as i can
i don't really even read anymore i read
audio books or i listen to audiobooks
i'm reading atomic habits right now
pretty good book
is there anything at the top of that
tower
is that the tower i'm thinking of
yes
that's not a tower like this is it
i don't believe so that's like a
different type of tower where you go
down
all right
so i believe
that this is ronnie
curse mark of death
and the in the heirloom
so if you look right here
that mark on her back
is the same
mark
that godwin has
so in the descriptions
in the description
whoops
or
what description
we've been told
that it was ronnie killed herself with
the rune of death and godwin
and then we have these
these bracelets they have little like
red hues on them there's two of them
her other arm
fell off
like burned
but this is ronnie's body
what else is there that we can look at
chat what does what does melano's
doesn't she wear something like that
around her or am i tripping
it's like kind of a scarf it's around
her neck
correct godwin lost his soul ronnie lost
her body
this would explain melania's um
burns on her hands too
is it the curse mark that says that
let's read it
let's read it
curse mark carved into the discarded
flesh of ronnie the witch there you go
also known as the half-wheel wound of
the centipede this curse mark was carved
at the moment of death of the first
demigod and should have taken the shape
of a circle however two demigods
perished at the same time breaking the
curse mark into two half wheels godwin
and ronnie ronnie was the first of the
demigods whose flesh perished while the
prince of death perished in seoul alone
so that's guaranteed
yeah is it a cape
i'm gonna throw this out there
his body is at the uh the roots of the
earth tree yes
i'm gonna throw this out there
does that not look like rodericka's
scarf
hold on
there is not a lot about this chick bro
it's kind of like her hoodie
that's a stretch
what secrets do you hold
miss
let me go around the back
um it's a stretch
they don't tell us nothing about this
chick man i think there's more to this
chick than meets the eye i really do
green medallion
on her neck
yeah right there
i don't know i feel like i'm on to
something bro bro
oh no
look at the ronnie class
this is what you're talking about right
the front
oh here we go
okay mental mental picture
back to ronnie
mental mental picture
ronnie's is red
mhm
[Music]
we know roderick has been
brought here to be grafted no
oh man that's it's a different color but
that looks pretty [ __ ] close dude
i don't know
[ __ ]
different color though
what is um
hold on
if i look at talismans
green
the er tree's old sap becomes amber
treasured as the most precious of jewels
in the age of godfrey
a primordial life energy resides inside
i don't think that's what we're seeing
right is this ronnie's
her tree's old sap becomes so same thing
same thing
yeah that's what we're told langton is
that she is just a a tarnish from beyond
the mist
set here to be grafted
for godric but she pussied out remember
that's what she tells us she gets scared
which uh you know i'd be scared too
interesting
these don't look exactly the same though
not seeing anything here
that curse mark is scary though
ow
but this little scarf man this little
hood
there's a set
such close were gifted to those who
departed on missions to faraway lands
from which they would never return
but what choice did they have having
seen the guidance of grace so this is
just a tarnished navy hood
which matches
roderick's hood as well with the little
medallion right here kind of like ronnie
right
right here
yeah
interesting
calls are a spirit tuner
all right
interesting okay okay
who the heck is still out here
alexander's still rocking it out there
okay
i think he just says that she has a
knack for spirit tuning
right
okay
so with ronnie going out on her mission
we can talk to eg
see what he says
oh yeah he said it reminds
him of somebody
good of you to right by
you here for spirit tuning
lady rani has departed on her journey
along the dark path of the emperion
from rana's rise
as she calls it it would not have been
possible without you
i know i'm pretty great
and moreover
her childhood warden
i express my deepest gratitude
you and only you
were ladies see like why we gotta do
blight like that you know like blight
did stuff right
he did things
you know
right
oh they ain't got no more threes here
thanks
the girl
you brought here she's crestfallen
and can scarcely swing a blade but she
has a gift for spirit tuning i saw one
like her long ago
their eyes shared the same hue
their eyes shared the same hue
i mean hugh technically means
color
well i just existed i feel like we do
him really dirty
like really really really dirty
chad who's got green eyes
i don't know
i'm curious
hold on
just
check
hmm
guy's doing right by his maiden
doesn't eg say that he's honest to a
fault
dude your eyes are dark as [ __ ] what the
hell
what
all these things have different colors
man can't make a connection
here i need you to look up
art
of thy want
to be born
to be born in me
freak
oh is he referencing an older game
i mean i'm trying to think of just
people in in elden ring i thought it
might be ronaldo but no
ronald's eyes are dark af
we don't know what ronnie's eyes really
look like because she's a doll
hmm
blake got the short end
short stick to be honest if ronnie
rebelled he automatically went mad like
some kind of defense mechanism to anyone
against the
golden order
yeah he kind of does like he goes nuts
like red eyes and everything
he's a dog
loyal straight forward think of that
that ronnie's like you know she's all
about the moon and [ __ ] and think of
wolves who howl at the moon
it all makes sense
how long has my boy huge had chains on
i don't know
i wonder if we have any dialogue with
him
demon lady who's demon lady
melania we don't do we even know what
she looks like
under the mask
helmet
oh i took you for dead no matt to lay
out your arms in about rodericka
what about her
yes he's half wolf would you watch over
rodericka are you out of your mind
who'd stay with an ugly brute who only
knows how to smith
absurd
besides she'd never agree to it
it's what she wants i refuse to believe
it
i don't doubt you but i know when
something's too good to be true
that's sad as [ __ ]
oh i need smithing stone threes
oh
all right where do i get smithing stone
threes
never mind we're we're lure hunting i
can do that in my own time
huge is awesome i love this guy there's
also a much deeper lore about him as
well
that i do want to do an eventual video
on he's hard to understand though
because he doesn't tell you much
it eventually burns off when we burn the
er tree that that [ __ ] breaks right
after
this hoe i am pleased to see you again
would you like me to hold you
once more no the blessing
you're mean
actually yes we should advance your
questline
what is the deal with the backs
blacksmith he praised america at one
point
i mean he is he is there
to help the tarnished
so he isn't trapped
because he says i'm not a prisoner don't
think he even he literally says
it's not that deep bro
not just like that but he says no don't
think too deep about don't don't think
too much on it i'm not a prisoner
he's trying to do right
to queen america because he is terrified
of her
but why would that why would america
want to help us
well actually she's trying to shatter
the elden ring ratagon stops us they're
the same [ __ ] person
but they're two different
consciousnesses
so while america shattered the elden
ring and was held up
like this in punishment when you fight
her at the end
radagon drops down to stop us
as he's trying to mend it
so that that doesn't make
as a sense
companion
where i come from
after i received the warmth and lifely
figure
from a number of champions
i lay
with the remains of an exalted
i was awakened
by the guidance of grace
and chaste from my birthplace
pray
be kind
despite all that
i still wish to be a deathbed companion
so please
let me hold you like this
as often as it takes
may i ask a favor my dear might i ask
something of you
could you please find the owner of this
dagger
and return it i think so too langton
a certain person gave it to me
as a gift it's a very precious thing
he does call her a [ __ ] you're right
so i would like for the original owner
to have it back
if you wouldn't mind yeah so i can slit
his [ __ ] throat i'd like you to find
the owner of it's a very
good day to you my dear
queen america really set up everything
didn't she that we're doing she set up
everything
and set it all into motion by shattering
the elden ring
who is this
that's her that's queen america yeah
that's that's queen america but it's all
like
so dark at the bottom
is it just the glare
no
wicked
the road is yet long a god not easily
failed
but one day without fail you will have
your wish so please grant me forgiveness
you came to challenge the demigods and
their god to slay them and as long as
you do i will always smith your weapons
because that's what queen america wants
hugh does whatever she wants
so
do you i think you
trapped himself
don't you think
so that he
is forced to do this
not like force but he
you know does it himself
very interesting okay let's go to uh
let's do the thing i wanted to do
where can i find
um
a mausoleum isn't there one out here
yeah i think
i don't remember
i think i think if i go there it's there
i killed d fia is bae now
how often do you get hugs in a souls
game right that's what i was saying
he came willingly but they locked him
out of distrust
that makes sense
off near
there it is
i was a little off
i haven't been over there yet
die
sheep
ha ha
um
[Music]
nice
okay let's get it
because i want to use i want to get the
full moon spell
oops
son of a [ __ ]
it seems like everyone's racist against
the tarnished as well aren't they
i'm bad at this
oh we're jumping
or
we're stopping
can i look up in your bell
hello
aha
is it like letting me do it now
oh come on
this seems strange
there we go
so cool
just
awesome
near the tower of return
i don't i don't know about often you
mean
oh you mean gideon off near
true that's a good question
sorry i'm like looking at it
okay ranala
we have a remembrance right
yes
so now i can
go back
landsweener kill kill or be killed
thousand percent
you're talking about this
as guy senior
you can shove it
give me an incantation come on
uh
our remembrance
let's throw that on
very cool spell
uh i'm getting rid of the comet the
comet sucks ass
oh that's not the one what do i
7d it
damn what are we at 65.
i'm about to pop all my room and see
what we get
we just need five levels we have two
hmm
it's not even going to get us close
i could restat respect
or
um
can i wear two of these
no
i didn't think so that'd be that'd be
crazy
incantations what about spells
hmm
can i i want to use ronald's full moon
at the end that should not be
that that would make sense that he uh
that would make sense ari that
gideon
wants to stop what queen america is
doing
right
he probably wants to follow the golden
order with ratagon
he still fears her which is why he would
want to stop us right that would make
that's the simplest answer
i think came across your channel the
other day gotta say i really enjoy your
videos and i'm really enjoying the
stream good to hear marky thank you man
i'm glad i'm really glad you like it
very happy to hear that thank you
i can stream for
now i'm in live two hours already [ __ ]
another 30 minutes around that
i like to stream about three hours a day
um
five days a week
that's my plan right now should be fun
yeah but that that would make the most
sense he knows that becoming elden lord
is exactly what she wants
yep
agreed
can i get smithing stones
smithing stone threes
from you
i mean she
i need smithing stone threes we could go
here and get them
in fact let's let's do that i need that
i want to upgrade a bit
wow
all right speed run skip
boom i'm the best gamer in the west all
right
we want to go
here
why she wants that though i'm still
trying to figure out
that's the ultimate question isn't it
why did queen america shatter the elden
ring why did she do that
because that goes
very well with what ronnie wants
i don't know
holy jellyfish
i don't need this
oh there's another one right here
i forgot
oh [ __ ]
ronnie wants to return the world of the
cosmos
so
would my theory of radagon
wanting to
or not ratagonic radon
because here's another question why
does radon hold the stars
to stop is it to stop ronnie
who is her that uh
radon is
ronnie's brother
but why does he why does he try to stop
her
i want to go up here real quick
if if that's what he's doing i i don't
know
yeah i didn't think that would be that
very interesting questions
all i have in this game are [ __ ]
questions that are never
answered with a hundred percent
certainty
die
die
[ __ ]
forget what's in here
no i need smithing stone threes dude
i didn't know there was another somber
back there
is that
i don't need the crack crystals
at all
these guys freeze
oh
yeah they do
yeah they do
use armor says something radon yeah
maybe
i think his talks about
the golden order i think
don't remember
i mean let me check
cause i i have his armor
the golden lion is said to symbolize
godfrey the first elven lord and his
beast
uh regent sirosh
from his younger youngest years or don
was naturally captivated by the lord of
the battlefield
godfrey right
so it's all it's all about godfrey
which
what with what rot [ __ ] it
with what ronnie wants
radon
godfrey doesn't
yeah
radon symbolizes godfrey so that's
that would make sense
why radon wants to stop her
right
if he figured it out
how he did
and
why
like was the war between radon and
melania just
just for
yeah erect
just for uh
there is a smithing stone three nice we
need six of those
was it just for the great runes like
just to get power like was that it is
there more to that
like why why did she fight him or why
did he fight her
i'm pretty sure it was just for the
power of the runes
right i i did hear that there's a lot of
mistranslation from uh japanese to
english
which i figured that
you know when when she says stuff like
i'm going to usher in a world of
darkness it's like well
that doesn't sound good
but that's not what she means
i think would you guys say that ronnie's
ending is the best ending
okay there's three we need six
i guess it depends on your perspective
of what would be the best for you you
know
four
sorry buddy but you are dead a
f
it's the least selfish well it's the
opposite of so well
is it
i was gonna say it's the opposite of
selfish
yeah
yeah actually
true
but definitely depends on what you think
is good or bad
the cutscene in the end instead the moon
came for the world
it came to pick up tarnish and ronnie
just picking them up
catching an uber
yeah hers is to just reset everything
which
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] with that honestly
i'm kind of [ __ ] with a reset
two three i think we have six
um we want to send this up
but i i agree with you the others are to
gain a lot of power
hey we did get a maiden
we did
i love how that became a meme
that has to be intentional by the
developers right that has to be
intentional
for them to just be like you ain't got
no [ __ ] bro
it's like really
come on you you know we're all gamers
bro and we you know we struggle with
that a bit
you
you
you
it's like man we know we struggle with
getting girls come on man
don't gotta rub it in like that
oh we gotta do a thing
i grabbed them too fast to see what i
got there
we're definitely getting plenty of
material in this cave though yeah we got
we got what we need
i got what i want
i got what i need
they say she's just a friend
they say she's just a friend
yeah what boss is down here it's the
it's the crystal boss right
i think
yeah
there's an area to jump up to there but
let's see this first
let's crystal these nuts
oops
oh we don't freeze huh
not with that armor on right now
there we go
yeah now you're freezing
doesn't look like the oh yep
even crystals can freeze
even crystals
can we look up here real quick
because i think there was a an area i
could drop into it seems like every
elevator in a mine shaft
has like a place you can like jump to
yep
aha
somber three we'll take it
better to have it than the not have it
okay and let's see
because i need
two somber nines two summer tens to
upgrade
you know the rest of my stuff
these are mainly for the shield so that
we can do more damage with the uh
what is it called carry in retaliation
yeah that that mine right there to the
north of the lake of lorena is such a
gold mine for smithing stuff
freaking gold mine my guy
after we do this i think we're gonna
call it a day
because i i need to edit a video that i
think you guys are going to like
no matter it's all the same oh now i can
talk about
ah
there she is so i told her everything i
know
i'm indebted to a spirit tuner i met
long ago
it was all i could do to honor her
i'm sorry i doubted you
is he talking about queen america
he says he's indebted
[Music]
ah
i don't i don't think he is
oh my oh my oh my oh yeah okay smithing
stone fives are what we're looking for
now
and somber five got it
yep
let's go
i just finished my new game plus play
through let's go dude
good [ __ ] good [ __ ]
thank you very
much i have you to thank don't i
blonde hair like blond hair like clean
queen america also but he has taught me
the noble toil of spirit tuning
i'm as yet unsure of what i might be
able to accomplish
but if i might be able to help you all
i'd certainly like to try
and if there's any chance to ease the
suffering of my dear men who were
grafted
well i certainly must try
rodrika the spirit tune apprentice
pleased to make your acquaintance hell
yeah you know what you're for now let's
go there's something you should know i
need to warn you about something
a little while ago someone started
lurking in the wing on the opposite side
of the round table
and i can hear
from all the way over there
the howling and wailing of spirits in
fear of a curse
i can even hear the repulsive twisted
malice in itself
a plethora of spirits in an unceasing
cacophony
i can't even imagine
how much suffering inflicted to who
knows how many souls
not even the crafting caused anything
like this to happen
you should keep your distance
i know you're strong but please
she she's talking about um the dung
eater right has to
you should keep be distance
yeah
okay cool
but
we don't know if like do we know the
eyes of queen america because she has
really bright green eyes
hmm
sorry
um
hard to say
i don't think we ever see your eyes
it's not yet
not yet boys okay
everybody
i'mma call it there
thank you for watching i appreciate you
know everyone coming in and talking in
the stream that's always what i'm here
to do is just kind of interact with the
community and while we uh search for
cool stuff in the game
um
i guess i like the stream it it's it's
weird to say that because i'm used to
streaming on twitch but make sure to
like it if you haven't already um go
check out all the other content i'm
still trying to get uh
situated with with youtube when it comes
to like
membership buttons and stuff i just have
to wait for um
them to get back to me on that but that
should be a thing here pretty soon
um but yeah we're gonna call it there
i'm gonna go edit a video that i think
you guys are really gonna like
um great stream appreciate it very much
thank you again i'll be back tomorrow
around noon again i stream my is to
stream
12 p.m cst
to
um wednesday through sunday so i'll
stream tomorrow take a couple days off
we'll be back on wednesday at noon for
two to three hours is usually what i try
to go for because editing and streaming
together takes up a lot of time and i
have school so
anyway appreciate you guys being here
thank you so so so much
i'll be back tomorrow same time tomorrow
peace out guys have a great rest of your
day or night bye bye